Priscilla is with us in Tampa Florida hi
Priscilla how are you hi I'm good my
question to you is I know you talked a
lot about when it comes to budgeting and
your money that you need to tell it
where to go rather than wondering where
it went just wait at the end of the
month would you say when it comes to
goal-setting that the same applies to
time management time and wondering where
it went let me know for that matter
every aspect of your life the more of it
you do on purpose the more of it you're
gonna have high-quality it in other
words if you're intentional like that
about your marriage or your intentional
about raising that baby that's sitting
in your lap or you're intentional about
whatever you're going to set specific
measurements by which you say I'm
winning okay and you know if you're like
you want to run a marathon then you
would that be winning you've complete
the marathon you do the training and the
steps to get there but the goal has a
very specific thing I mean you get this
child is specifically I wanted ours to
leave and stay gone until they brought
back grandbabies and so I wanted to
raise children that could become adults
not just be good children and and be
critical thinking skills and so forth so
you set goals in every area of your life
some of them are a little bit more
difficult to measure with math but it's
something that you can do very easily
okay how do you stick to it what are
ways a good ways to stick to those well
to those things you know it's really two
things that motivate us and all and
we're all pretty much that way and it's
old basic psychology 101 and it's pain
and pleasure the pain that happens if I
don't stick to it if I don't stick to my
diet I end up severely overweight and on
the operating table having a business
biscuit ectomy in my heart and because
of too many biscuits so if I don't stick
to it I get pain right if I don't take
care of my marriage I get pain called
marital problems if I don't take care of
my if I don't spend time pay attention
these kids they end up you know being
taken care of by somebody else I get
pain the rehab center or something like
that and so when you get pain as one
motivator as your why so what happens
when you don't manage your time well I
feel disorganized I feel frustrated my
stress level goes up and I'm working on
the wrong things I end up spending time
on stupid things and then I have a an
emotional hangover called regret right
and then the pleasure side is when I do
this right I feel so much better when I
do this right with money I have money
when I manager the time right wow I have
this sense of accomplishment I have this
sense of I am achieving I'm doing the
right things with every hour to squeeze
and the the zest out of this life that I
can and I'm gonna play hard I'm gonna
work hard and I'm gonna do it
intentional even when I'm relaxing I'm
gonna do that on purpose
a budget an hour to sit on the back
porch with a cup of coffee and prayer
time with my Bible in my lap I'm gonna
budget that in my in my time budget so
pain and pleasure are what motivate me
what about you you're absolutely right I
guess I never really thought it thought
about it like that but yeah I would
agree that it would be that yeah and so
you know the thing is that one of the
things I wrote in an early book and it's
really a bad phrase but I still like it
and I get quoted on it but it's it's a
poorly worded but only when the pain of
same exceeds the pain of change will you
change if only the pain of where you're
sitting is big enough and you know so
when people call me and go like I'm
ready to get out of debt that's because
they're got disgusted with where they
are enough to go through mean the pain
of sitting in the debt is greater than
the pain it takes to sell stuff and work
an extra job and get on a budget to get
out of debt now they're ready to change
but only then do we change very seldom
do we just rise up and change sometimes
we do but that's the most noble parts of
ourselves when we're able to do that
most of the time it's like pain kicks
your butt and you go I am so sick of
being frustrated stressed out I'm going
to manage my time I'm so sick of feeling
I'm gonna back away from the chocolate
chip cookies that's me talking to me
right there and so you know I mean I'm
so sick of dot dot dot I'm sick and
tired of being sick and tired I've had
it
let's Brown the great motivator says
that phrase and he says when you do that
when you have that I've had it moment
when the pain of where you are the pain
of same exceeds the pain of change only
then will you change you haven't I've
had it moment that's not a wonderful
question Thank You Priscilla appreciate
you bringing that up and then when you
set the goals folks will take that step
further past her question when you set
the goals you start asking yourself what
has to be true
about my life that's not true now for me
to get the be one of those to do one of
those things what has to be true we
start having kids I well I started
realizing I don't know how to raise kids
they didn't come with a manual and had
me and had me a manual how to work on
these little critters and so I had to
read all the manuals I started reading
parenting books left and right start
listening to focus on the family so I
could focus on my family and all that
kind of stuff so you have to learn if
they learn what has to be true life and
know something that I don't know today
in order to be something tomorrow that
I'm not today and have things tomorrow I
don't have today in my life
[Music]